you want to live hard you want to live
clean you want to live optimized we know
there's one company that does not
compromise you know I'm saying are you
rapping right now happen must be on
alpha brain you want to talk about on it
bro on everything yes dude on it calm
slash fight or a little alpha brain
little new mood maybe you want some
melatonin really want to sleep better
yeah man how about some creatine so we
can get Jack city how about shroom tech
immune or how about just shroom tech and
general if you want to work out extra
how about a little krill oil to get that
skin right literally everything you want
including exercise about fitness gear
they got it check you want some Star
Wars on it kettlebells what now ropes
ropes bags balls clubs maces how about
you need a training program we got that
on it six kettlebell on it 6 steel mace
they got it all streaming easy apparel
shirts shorts backpacks socks
performance gear audit comm slash
fighter 10% off get yourself
hey B there's a lot of tools out there
that track your heart rate they might do
a thing here or there maybe you're on a
bike like I am I'm like damn I burned a
thousand calories but I'm not yeah or
how about you think you're getting good
rest you think you're doing the things
right you think a good diet but you're
not really tracking it right you're not
tracking with the best device possible
you mean you talk about whoop what about
will form is tool change the way people
track the fitness and optimize their
training it really is kind of amazing I
mean before I even knew about it you
were wearing it and I said you you were
you're comparing it to other I've had a
bunch of watches yeah and you said this
was the best by far the best you were a
customer before you this this became
select loop is a performance tool you
get a whoop strap which is a heartrate
monitor that measures your heart rate a
hundred times per second 24 hours all
that stuff 24/7 you can charge it while
you want you don't even take it off just
put on the little battery it charges it
usually lasts about five days mine lasts
a little longer so five days without a
charge yeah so what's would measure like
what am I gonna do though your recovery
look at your heart rate you make sure
you're getting the right rest if you're
not zero your strain how well you're
working out it checks your resting heart
rate max heart rate calories burned the
of exertion you're putting out
throughout the day your sleep - all that
REM deep light it does all that man it
provides all these insights down to the
nitty gritty and you got to get the new
whoop 3.0 strap that's what you need to
do go to whoop go to whoop calm whoop
there it is wh Oh Oh Pete calm use the
code fighter at checkout save $30 to
optimize the way you train again that's
whoop calm promo code fighter for $30
off the way you got to do it right to
track your train and get to shred Sadie
treads do it I've been wearing makeup
all week dude you're practically today
even I'm [ __ ] prickly dude are you
prickly because you were wearing makeup
all week or because you're not with me
oh well um well I'm pretty [ __ ] I'm
pretty and I'm bristly and I'll tell you
this I'm oh hey hey Internet
I'm sick and tired and when my voice
gets deep you know I'm dead serious
yes I'm sick and tired of you guys
suggesting I'm old rate
Frank's tart tart Nass and [ __ ] look
at the dents and lines in his face
some of the comments there still are so
funny people are just so ruthlessly old
this is why my dad shouldn't have a
smartphone dude but whenever I post a
picture with you it's just oh man y'all
chill at a town I don't even dad bro
sweet Pig I don't read the comments but
now I read them to see how mean they can
be and it's just you got a head like an
insurance salesman you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just crazy [ __ ] man he's I don't
know it's the it's the meanest funniest
[ __ ] you know I want you to apologize to
the fine kid listeners for doing a
podcast on Thursday I want to apologize
to everybody I've been on set doing
reshoots daddy had daddy had a lot of
pretending to do this week a lot of
pretending that he makes Bank pretend
daddy makes Bank Haley came to my set oh
it's awesome yeah I love her I know I
was like you should have [ __ ] cuz she
texts me goes hey at your show tonight
but I was on stage I didn't see it I got
off and like cut who is this and I've
who dis D is who discourteous with the
eggplant emoji just kidding just back
who dis eggplant oh yeah
yeah she's a tail if they got [ __ ]
yeah just said hi
great cow talented um you're shooting
Goldberg's of school shooting schooled a
lot of on location football stuff and
what was really feel foreign to you to
be on a football field III got you know
III have speed by the way forty yards is
much longer than I gave it credit for I
do say I run a for whatever that's a
really long like if you're not used to
it it's actually very long looking to me
it's not short no you're like well quite
stupid like thrown a football 40 yards
is not that easy it's not a given
maybe yeah but the thing is it's stupid
to make linemen run 40-yard dash because
they never run a 40-yard dash
they then run side to side but let's
just be tenured deaths right bad boys
right 10 yards like why why of 40 but
now the football field well all the
extras were there and they're all the
football players some big kids and then
there was a guy who was not only huge
but impossibly muscular and supposed to
be high school I bet you didn't talk to
him at all I walked up to him and I went
here there you go I go you look like a
pro football player sure you don't you
can't fit miss it was I was he goes I
was high go are you worried goes yeah I
play for the Cardinals I go okay and so
can I go would you play and he goes
defensive tackle and I'm crazy-crazy
just light rider black kid white kid and
just a monster and obviously it was it
they're looking at a camera and they go
well that doesn't make sense I mean
everybody's big butts to baby who it
just looks like a pro athlete outcast is
it so did they kick they cut him from
the scenes yeah he couldn't he yeah
great guy great guy name is late his his
cousin or brother I think it's his
cousin is in the WWE he plays a [ __ ] I
can't remember the guys name I shouldn't
know it's kind of a famous guy but it
comes from was just a giant family
they're all like these and he's trying
to get into acting yeah just a good guy
just a good [ __ ] guy
that's Kadim yeah see you later well no
no sir you you're you're huge you're
gonna distract from that and and and
unmistakeably looks like a real athlete
like you're like oh you know Jesus
played for the Cardinals for a hot so
yeah yeah see we're gonna have Brian
guest before that is tell about a
terrible game yeah Randy Orton maybe oh
no his dad his dad's uh Mick Foley
that's cool come on yeah
all right Oh dad's Booker T do you watch
your wrestling excuse me sorry I'm
questioning no one doesn't hit chin I
hear be honest I'm surprised you don't
watch pro Wyatt rest I don't know I'm
surprised feel like it might be a little
bit of your flesh oh no as a kid baby
yeah yes a kid I did that it must be a
blast to do although it's physically
show to me I think it's a blast Kurt
Angle Tamara he had more injuries from
from pro wrestling by far than wrestling
yeah yeah well I was never like jumping
off [ __ ] laughs yeah yeah yeah I find
it that I respect what they do and I
know it's hard I find it so embarrassing
when I watch it well then I cap the
wrist off oh I'm like oh dude that guy's
4d acting like that but the best is the
guy who uses his dong what he'll put
your hand on his dong and he flips you
you've seen it what in the WWE what yeah
he's got yeah with you have big phat
dong power somebody have you not seen
this awesome guy he's the greatest of
all time no I don't watch it really he's
a famous wrestler crotch yeah he throws
you what's his name
WD Razak riders cross zack ryder is that
rider zack ryder I don't know whoa yeah
I'm not mad at her
no nor should you be this is a Q&A dude
the WWE Diva girls are hot enough to
make yeah there is there is exactly he
throws dudes he through this phase but
just have put Josh and I are throwing
dudes with his crotch if this is his
move
I'm sure we should put yeah whatever his
name is throwing dudes especially if
it's dick it's his move it's gonna pop
up yeah he's a stud and this is real
yeah be able to see this is real no this
is real dudes are you sure it's that
writer I don't know it's just it's all
just malarkey in it it just says you but
I think a lot of it's true
it's so strange I don't know the guys
name is he's awesome now Cain Cain
Velasquez is doing it enjoying it good
for him Naoko become until once
eventually get into it like jail this is
this a lot of guys a lot of money
oh yeah it's messed with it I don't
there's not a lot of money again it's
like the UFC only the top guys are
making money if you talk to any of you
guys even the real famous ones I do did
until you get to a certain level you're
not making a comment actually it's just
like yeah if I thought about there on
the road 300 days a year like you're not
you're not Scrooge McDuck rich unless
you're the rock or Batista or like a
different level and you know even the
rock now in his movies has to be Dwayne
Johnson cuz WB he owns the name the rock
oh yeah yeah they get a certain
percentage whatever uses the rock rock
what would your name be if you were I
know what mine would be ground hey brown
what if you couldn't use big brown I got
I gotta get some royalties on that kind
of wet my beak yeah you don't how do you
beat you've been a little rink have you
little rank yeah you you're the rinks
rinks I'm rank rank rank ease wrinkle
wrinkles dual just wrinkles but then the
crowd yells ranks ranks wrinkles and
dense wrinkles and dense wrinkles and
dense no just wrinkles now um but I feel
like I'm also small so I'd have to have
baby in there or no no no no you're not
you're not a real wrestler you're like
you're like the the guy who's like oh
yes my precious
yeah yeah Undertaker yeah the Paul bear
you're my Paul bear I am big ground and
rinks I don't like this you know be in a
suit whatever you say er how I just yell
weird [ __ ] from the fries Brian he's
[ __ ] sued come on
like in an alternate universe you know
all the choices that be made all the
wrong choices yeah give me a second man
okay I can't afford [ __ ] blow so I'm
snorting adderall you can imagine how
what a life that is like Penn & Teller
which one doesn't talk
is it teller you think I hate this
[ __ ] life like he's just like oh I
can do this again yeah but dad don't
talk to the mother
yeah that's your gimmick right that's
your all the time when you have a when
you have a gimmick that you have to
stick with yeah when you have a routine
then yeah that's your schtick they used
to call it a stick no he would say until
he's dying inside on the right well
they're just getting over it made a lot
of money I guess Oh a ton of money yeah
that that that's when Penn was Vic he
was thick oh my god 400 pounds was he
that fat he's tall man very tall but
he's vegan now so he's real skinny uh
Wow all right yeah he's a lot skinny how
long they've been doing entertainment
dude a long time man a long time the
they they're great and so yeah I've
never been to the show cuz hey biggest
shows but um I heard it's great I'm sure
it is
they're great um the kids mother's these
mother brothers Smothers Brothers
remember them well I don't they were
amazing they were blooming groups Blue
Man Group I saw I was they pulled me
onstage
really yeah did you splash some pain I
was there at the same night that Jeff
Goldblum was there we were both brought
up on stage I'm just blessed patron I I
didn't I was put in the mold it's it's a
funny about this story [ __ ] hilarious
with the Blue Man Group do you know how
they put you in that that that gel never
in the again what's funny is then dude
we don't know yeah I'm a twin there okay
so what's funny about it is that that's
something that you would definitely
remember as I tell the story I was
brought up onstage as I tell the story
though I can't remember if that happened
to me or if they did something else with
me I don't know if I'm lying it was that
long ago I'm not kidding and I I'm not I
was brought up on stage I have a witness
to it but I camera
I did I can't remember if I saw LeBron
on stage are you look hold on I know
what's going on here yeah you think it
was the Blue Man Group is David
Copperfield and you ended up on an
island that's what it was
remember that's what it was did he get
all the hold me to thing yeah is he
still making things disappear you feel
me yeah I feel I think he got busy yeah
just be his billboards everywhere dude I
heard that Criss Angel show is to die
for
really I heard it's gay he wasn't doing
for a hot second yeah he's just like
SOPA Posterous he looks so it's like
dude affliction ended a long time look
yeah he's up very happy with his torso
with his hold up jeans let's see him
here looks better this here plate again
you know what's Bank that dudes making
but at the end of the day it doesn't
matter how much money you have in your
bank count we muster head on that pillow
it's gonna say you got [ __ ] III who
it's cool there yeah but I was gonna say
that's right if well well Jen don't give
a cool one of them go to the ridiculous
one of them well he would go to demonic
he would go to David plain when David is
about public spectacles he would go
there and hand out his card he was a
hustler
he made his I bet you I bet you we'd
like him I bet he's all I bet you either
end up like in the dirt I bet he's I
mean you can't again exactly he's very
good at what he does stays in shape
handsome dude you know a little silly
but why not why not why if you built
like that why not wear chains and and
break up behind freak he's got a he's
got great eyes he looks like your friend
oh great really he looks like Frank's
more sensitive less muscular he looks
like Frank's emo little brother yeah
that's what he looks like
yeah he looks like emo Frank what is it
look up his nationality I'm gonna say
Italian I'm gonna say black magic yeah
he might be from Mordor but I but he's
good I've seen some of this she does
it's really good man which is a show but
I want to see what his religion is her
worries were hit me as a bunch of kids
oh he's Greek he's Greek says Greek yeah
yeah angels Greek Christopher Nicholas
Sarah
Sarah caucus or whatever damn he's 51
dude Wow yeah it looks good
originally Borini or weak sir somebody
muscle meal in the world he's from New
York the Greeks are very good-looking
people what a hustler he's my age 51 you
know what I was watching last night I've
seen it the 30 30 on Dennis Rodman
uh-huh and he talks about how baek's I
was falling a little sleep this but he
bit you so he was in Detroit right he
grew up kind of weird and then he was in
he had drafted by the Detroit Pistons
was doing his thing but net he was like
real shy and then the he thought he was
gonna be there forever he's never had a
family felt like the team with his
family so that team dispersed cuz it's
professional sports no one stays
together forever he's there for seven
years goes from there to the San Antonio
Spurs and there's finally like oh I'm
gonna be myself so he starts dyeing his
hair he starts while in the [ __ ] out
doing things hanging out at gay clubs
wearing dresses makeup they talked about
a little bit I think that being bisexual
Oh being bisexual and like having
fantasy about having sex with dudes so
Fran and then I saw some screenshot and
because my brother was the biggest
Dennis Rodman fan he had the shoes the
green ones they call him the worm and
there's a screen shot that goes des
Rodman talks about being bisexual engage
so I'm like that and so I screenshot
steps with my brother go favorite player
growing up you know he's gay am I really
no way I'm again do I did you don't wear
a dress to sell a book and just be cool
with it yeah and not have some dicks in
your mouth something's going on yeah go
back up that was him back in the day huh
right there mm-hmm yeah huh
when he was a Detroit bring it up woody
wait I hear bisexual before I misquote I
also heard he had a son and then his
sound daughter
hey come who's that no malko worker he
had a daughter then just wasn't around
she and she grows up she's like I didn't
have a dad like he thought by just
sending toys and [ __ ] he's being a dad
well I heard that he lost custody of the
child or something I don't know no no
you gotta watch the documentary be you
don't have to hear anymore he tells you
guys he tells you like yeah I just
wasn't there I got a divorce from the
mom my
he starts crying about it of course yeah
I'm sure he's a very very he's an odd
guy but he's a very sensitive guy scroll
up a little bit sometimes may not
control huh I think they were saying I
was mmm dad I think the worst things
that I was doing that people called bad
me drunk driver and we go in jail was
the best thing that happened me and then
all the good things happen for better
worse because I was building this
individual okay building a brand
one thing I was proud of back then
actually brought the gay community to
the forefront of sports because the
things I was doing I did sports
Ostreicher I went in a bathing suit and
had makeup on and stuff like that and I
was flamboyant when I was doing it and
stuff like that people are like wow this
guy because he's not afraid to go out of
the box I just think the percentage-wise
the sports thing is a lot there's
probably more bisexual than gay in
sports
I'm sorry guys exposed everybody I wish
all of them would come out acceptable
today hold up
I don't know any man on this planet any
man on this planet that don't go into
the shower and look at another man I
don't know any man that don't do that
gay or not gay I care who you are
a man's gonna look at another man I
don't give a damn how you look at it
he's not gay though but you got pride of
that image interesting well of course I
do
well yeah but I don't look at that man
and go man I wish his dick was in my bun
right different animal yeah I mean you
do but sometimes you know I'm saying I'm
your we all know your 51-yard gay man 12
IQ minute his both yeah
yeah but to me it was so obvious like he
wears a straight-up wedding dress dude
like that's not he's he's his attention
there's just all right so nothing like
what was the idea of how did it all
change probably he always wanted to kind
of be like he'll if I was always in the
fashion always in the decoration not
right I mean he talked to like he it's
almost like you built this dense trauma
opens up his relationship with gay men
so he was dating Madonna for a bit then
she wanted a baby and he broke up with
her um what about I like when athlete
now I can understand when athletes we
were talking about how Odell Beckham
wore a $250,000 watch yeah what he
didn't pay for it though right and I was
like well there's a great marketing
whatever he did it's silly talking up
here's the problem in he's one of my
favorite players but he was probably not
winning so it's a distraction you're not
winning so if you're winning if you're
winning you can wear that if you're my
home and your ball and you can wit you
can do that stuff but when you do that
stuff you're not winning then it's just
a distraction they're a team especially
when your team didn't execute they
weren't disciplined and then you're
doing this like that ain't the time to
do it man there's a time to do it
that ain't the time what is this is that
really him it looks like him hmm
yeah I don't think Rodman says he no it
doesn't say he's gay
no he doesn't he doesn't care I think
he's a spy
I think he's bi he's bisexual yeah he
says that right you mentioned bisection
yeah like you don't wear all that [ __ ]
like you don't let me go to the other
quote where says bisexual or maybe he
just likes bisexual people I don't know
it's very possible he's not gay
right here it's I don't think he's gay I
think he's by you don't wear dresses and
do whatever it is he's just complicated
well he's talking about bisexual
laughing yeah so he's not kind of at him
no again again fellas fellas could be
you gotta listen to the documentary cuz
he says out of his mouth yeah yeah he's
bi yeah he says yeah yeah he's that
fantasy's found sex with men since he's
a child okay this isn't like a rule I
hear say the documentary bro he said
yeah oh yeah what dude you rather beat
around the bush he came out the
documentary on Tuesday man he addresses
all this hell says he was more famous
than Jordan for three years and you know
what a lot of players agreed with him
zoos as famous as Jordan for three years
he definitely was in the United States
it was I don't know about two all over
the world but he definitely well-known
there you go mm-hmm oh yeah bad as I
want to be my brother had that book I
think he's on the front on a motorcycle
so that's where he said he was bisexual
your brother didn't
I think my brothers bought the book now
what a like Madonna's legend but um they
were saying how one of the reason when
rodman did get his famous is Jordan's
because he was dating Madonna's that got
picked up if that's true even John
Salley who's a teammate's like Robin was
big but there's no way we know Rodman
like Rodman if he wasn't dating Madonna
do you know John Salley you ever met him
no I know John pretty well yeah great
guy really cool guy smart smart guys
like that I miss him I wonder what he's
doing ABS he was on the scene for a
while doing stuff different he was in LA
and I don't know I haven't seen that 30
the 30 for 30 schools Jamie Foxx is
narrating it I love I need to watch more
than 30 oh this is so good Junior say I
want to make you cry anyone in here seen
the June seonghwan used talked about it
though yeah you ready for that cannabis
entrepreneur actor vegan and B yeah he's
great
dude that when they show the highlights
of the Detroit Pistons you know in the
was it early 90s when they're the bad
boys dad how about a different game I
mean night and day it just just rougher
uh more caution to the wind or Walkman
yeah like like like Rother it's pirates
yeah yeah it up like I gonna play is
reading it [ __ ] up yeah everybody knew
that shows him like pushing out in
Jordan and like taking Scotty picked me
like toss them in the crowd oh ho Rodman
I mean you know beer Laimbeer they were
they were nasty man mm-hmm Isiah Thomas
as nobody was really watching you didn't
have they were value that were they
watch him but you don't have the the
Twitter yeah one for cetera soup
everything was making news and yeah now
you have tattletales now you got a bunch
of narcs watching everything you do oh
yeah you know you just did you got
tattletales everywhere tattletales
everywhere ruining all the fun those
Pistons beat Jordan yeah there's the
team there yeah I wouldn't be surprised
if Isiah Thomas will go by to a her room
who speaks them all huh I've heard
rumors handsome guy is he I think
someone who's you
looks like a black Doug a black what
Doug the cartoon Doug good-looking guy
man man I don't think bring him bring up
eyes hair I would say the good-looking
too very expressive one lady in the room
whoa that's a different Isiah Thomas how
do you spell is another no see that's
Isiah Thomas the third put in Isaiah
Thomas Detroit there you go there you go
there it is there it is there you go huh
now when he was a young man that's
that's now he's older now he's my age go
to go that bottom one the face changes
as we get older not that weird face gent
the bottom far right second row in
second huh yes one two second row last
picture square draw you're saying last
row second row yeah I mean built like a
you know like a Greek god yeah dad the
only woman that lets like if they'd like
to be gay to make sure though he's no
I'm telling you not known as like a
ladies man like there is cat if you
think Carlton's hot from [ __ ] Fresh
Prince of bel-air you're gonna love I
say it Tom yeah but look at her mm-hmm I
think your exact him cuz he's athletic
no I just thought he was always that
fairly handsome dude he's good-looking
in a goofy way mm-hmm that's not good
yeah that's not sexy there you go
that's what that's Isaiah Thomas yeah I
like me yeah there you go yeah hey go
has that Luke Rockhold er Isaiah Thomas
can you get in man I could do in the old
gaming hey man what'd you say what were
you saying
nothing don't talk behind my back like
this when we're doing a podcast yeah
there are some uh yeah when he speaks I
love how they had short shorts just
makes so much sense why they were the
bag you ones out there starting to get
short was that well who came up with the
cross Joe I was gonna say it was Jordans
the one that did that and Jordans one
that wore his own shoes they got fine
like a [ __ ]
so unschooled last year we talked about
that in one of the episodes where I
start wearing culottes because my team
invite one of my students is wearing
that what the hell and what
it's 91 or something I mean I joined the
one who started yeah he's starting it so
that's his rookie season and then and
then you'll see he's the one that made
the baggy shorts thing is if I have you
would probably if I'm quoted out like
that I'm wearing on blast them wearing
my cheeks out the back yes dude
I don't I don't get why boxers do it
either like you leave some of the trade
there down D agree but it never came
back the short shorts never came back
they've never made a comeback I'd be in
spandex well short shorts are starting
to come back to us are they LeBron and
some other guys are starting to wear
shore to shore
we're not like Isaiah short we are nuts
about them no but LeBron should be in
the old school Isaiah shorts dude I know
you'll see you'll see high school kids
too like you'll see a lot of these other
kids aren't aware shortest shorts see
those aren't super baggy still baggy
they're still not showing the thigh dude
yeah everybody's covering their body out
trying to see the dick piece in the
front those guys right and then they
were spandex underneath
yeah but he's wearing spandex underneath
but still why does he wear spandex like
that is that easy muscles tight stay
warm go on the bench but see those are
those are at least smaller than the way
some kids wear yeah I don't get why you
wouldn't wear just short shorts dude I
agree with you they make slaughter on
start doing that dude I'd be shorts on
the other day one out myself it might
even my son his daddy have short shorts
okay too short that if he's noticing
than too short I'm too short little too
short daddy of short shorts he's yeah
yeah they'd old school you know the old
school running shorts you used to go
running it's when I wear toe run I feel
like you could get away with it yeah
yeah it mixed signals if you're not hip
to the fashion mixed signals oh man yeah
running - that's it is a gay it is a I
do see gay men wearing those shoes yeah
you guys have fast you're signaling the
gay guys on the floor it's about sexual
signaling yeah right so you're doing
that in your name what it is me wearing
short shorts or guys have like a little
bit of quads on in winter Schwartz is
like yoga pants for hot [ __ ] there you
go what are you doing leave something no
imagining I like them I like the way
they look
dude come on well can you go back
research not that shirt that's now that
one if you could go down no oh
we're gonna cheeks or hey yeah if you
could show us the single oh there you go
the singlet work now we're trying is to
wrestle it now that does have what I
wrestling that's a good luck right there
I'll buy those and in post an Instagram
of me and those that that's hilarious
yeah short Schwartz just makes and they
just make sense
hmm I like short shorts man feels that's
aggressive but my swim trunks are really
short but gals tend to not really like
that they like sometimes I say [ __ ]
these hoes that's what I do
okay and I just do what's comfortable
all right well you're not gonna wear
those which one's the white ones they're
the guys got a very good physique but a
little dick though I can't wear those
yeah oh well now now that's better luck
can't were your chicks get up shorts
well those are those are all your hold
up I would took my kid for ice cream
another day in Calabasas the girl she
has an apron on in the front she turns
right she goes you want to come for
Cohen caprica yo what do you want to get
Conan cool she turns out to get the cone
her ass cheeks were hangin until I'm
saying dude it hurt these shorts covered
three inches yeah her [ __ ] was in
everybody's face any dad makes me good
she turns around he's he's like hold his
daughter's hand and like talking his
life's turned on us oh Jesus and he
seemed like look away but then we both
right even I was like oh [ __ ] cuz I
don't know she's my 18 so the guy goes
oh Jesus and he looks at his wife goes
why here we go oh [ __ ] it was you could
see that there was so short yeah I went
people of like the brown around their
[ __ ] you could see the brown almost
dude that's that's him yeah she was
getting this mint chocolate ice cream
that's a commitment [ __ ] with that
that's a real commitment I mean it's
just we dislike kids do these yeah you
used to see the outer rim you could see
the nudges the outer rim yeah yeah yeah
you can see the the
it's crevices that lead to that my
favorite part is all the dads that's
right that's what I was uh even a little
worse a little worse so she's wearing a
thong for shorts is what she did denim
denim thong well analyst and I didn't
like that that is really nice dude I
swear to God almost i down cut now she
didn't look like that okay so that's a
big problem
she looked like that didn't help the
cheeks out the back either yeah some
girls the confidence it is a hot girl
summer and they just have to cellulite
hanging out my gift for you girl well I
I love it when the girls have the
midriff and this have the guts sticking
out like oh wow yeah at the Sears in
1985 I saw a similar situation with this
gal it was very big and she had
impossibly short shorts on and I and I
remember looking going that's that's
that's confidence that's there's
something yeah she's just celebrated and
I I swear to God as I walk by her friend
goes I never forgot her friend goes so
can I just tell you like this is Emma
this is all I heard of the concepts so
can I just say that when you wear shorts
like that and that's all her I was like
would that take a difficult conversation
I don't I don't mind it and I like the
chubby bunnies that get in those like
the you know that the confident you have
to look in the mirror and go [ __ ] yeah
yeah and then roll out with that chili
bowl and you know it's a lot of it's
like guys who are just heavy as hell and
they just they just don't give a [ __ ] or
some fun you got like thing maybe sure
what kind of bike is oh that is
definitely a Schwinn is that a Schwinn
that's a sway I never know that's a
swing beach cruiser oh that's a beach
cruiser right the beach but um yeah oh
um when it when it when creatures on a
woman wears well let's girls get my
script here it is when a woman wears
rides a bike sometimes there can be a
situation situation I saw a guy with
butt implants and I was with Chris
D'Elia and we were at the coffee bean Oh
God
decree he had him up and he walked chris
goes as we're talking we're talking what
something else in Christmas
and definitely don't do that your but
I'm sorry there's oh my hold up
check out the cheekers where were you
chin oh no we're right this one there
the fourth one in that is so bad
yeah plastic surgery on a man doesn't
look so good Joey pics has spent
thousands to get pleasant ass with the
Brazilian the Brazilian where they take
the fat from your tummy and put in your
ass oh yeah dude I've seen them in
person
live in the flesh it ain't terrible man
now no that's not your remote that's
cool that's unfortunate that's difficult
yeah yeah well wow that has to hurt yeah
well I I my friend's girl did that she'd
she got the fat put in her and she
couldn't sit down for six weeks and she
had to wear compression they you were a
compression thing and you get massaged
so they massage the fat with it so worth
it and then after six weeks friend all
good baby
Brendon take it easy dude look at Nicki
Minaj Accardi be hey hold up chin scroll
up you're going oh that might be the
same guy that the jealous think wow I
guess gay guys human beings have always
done they've always altered their body
in any way they can't from plate in
their limbs to their men want to do that
there you go one thing I got is a booty
on me I'd like to have arms and they
have bigger arms better chest but you
know can't have it all burn I'd rather
have a booty than like then a flat ass
you know yeah you can't there's nothing
we're like skinny arms alright whatever
but a flat ass yeah yeah gluteal
enhancement how many guys are getting
passes well I just can't wait til they
are able to is listening to David
Sinclair on Rogan who is the guy who
talks about how they can bring back your
aging by you know 10 years eventually
and all that stuff
do you say when well it's not that far
wall tourism with human growth hormone
DHEA and metformin there is a the human
beings they've identified a clock on
humans like a
actual biological clock if you will and
there's a molecule you can look at or a
a mitochondrial or DNA it's something in
the DNA and it can actually tell you
when you're gonna die according to
Sinclair yeah man they can start to
pinpoint how long you have and then you
can start to take these drugs like
informants of that just turns it back
two and a half years at this point
that experiment was only with 9p pay two
and a half thanks for nothing thanks for
nothing right oh that's all for nine and
a half yeah last two and a half a barely
see Kenny yeah bed but the idea would be
that intent like that the idea is when
you're 80 they might be able to bring
your biological clock back to when you
were 30 so you can do physical things
and be you know that's the idea I mean I
think a lot of it's wishful thinking I
mean I do believe that we are well did
the she that lived at 200 or something
like that
the first so when born harm fear is get
a 150 the medium age is gonna grow like
crazy yeah
because we will have viruses that they
can shoot in your eyes and to you know
all that stuff but so much of this the
thing yeah they said the first person
there's been a person born who's gonna
live 150 so it there you go
I like that idea because you can you can
pick him an instrument now I had that
guy on my podcast
Aubrey de Grey he's dead Posey the lead
singer of Robbie Robbie he studies the
seven different seven different
mechanisms in which the human cell
breaks down and they're studying they're
studying those mechanisms and then how
to stop it
mitochondria so but is it true someone
that is gonna live 150 years it's just
like what says the first person who
lived 250 has already been born
revisited yeah mutations the
mitochondria intracellular aggregates
junk inside the cells
do you her fit to me sick well what
would be cool living come fluent in the
piano you could keep talking about
pianos and [ __ ] or I spent a lot of time
with my family you know that would be
nice down
[ __ ] the piano dude yeah but why am i
son to modern 50 yeah that's pretty cool
too yeah yeah yeah that was a piano now
dude well I like the idea of mastering
different things and have
a lot of time to do it you know I don't
know
would I be doodle in the piano now I'm
you're never gonna be [ __ ] eye to eye
don't rip an affair how'd it work out um
it's just there's a technical
proficiency you've got to get to before
you can actually you can learn chords
and actually learn how to play certain
songs and make a lot of work it's it's
where I loved it I love love I love love
love the drums in piano cuz I like the I
like the tactile I like the primer used
to have a drum so that your old how I
started I still did it I love it I love
practicing stick sticks and like all the
stuff that should I love I really do but
that's more I like the feel of it you
can learn how to play the drums if you
really practice in a year and you can
play all my plays look at the bongos he
learned in like three months
yeah boom boom my dad's big bongos yeah
I came home one day after college and
said bongos if ya honor than three
months my Johanna Mar my buddy who you
know his son Louie unless I got them
drunk oh my god can he play does though
yeah I mean he practices six seven eight
hours dude and now his band is becoming
huge he's that kid is like he's always
been artistic and now he's a monster on
the drums dude that's like a whole
nother level of drums you're just like
oh [ __ ] you look at my boy Travis Barker
he's playing his drums with his eyes
closed yeah of course the whole thing
just eyes closed I will say the same so
I played the piano for a year cuz I
wanted I wanted I wrote a play about a
piano player don't ask and like the
movie piano though oscar-winner it's
called the American piano player now I
was a [ __ ] I don't want it was that
though I actually did it I did it as a
one-act and it was really did a
one-minute it was really good but I
didn't play the piano on it but um I
remember I got a point where I was
playing so much that I I was able to use
the weight of my fingers like I like
literally you could just you you get to
a point where you can just use the way
to your fingers to play yeah it's so
effortless that I was just playing
chords I wasn't playing like you know
but you can get to apply mister it was
really cool but I
like oh [ __ ] this is and I had a teacher
who showed me he would break down songs
and you could actually play that you can
the song is it yeah yeah Oh gentlemen
the great Raja Chola saved us oh I love
how you just walked in it's great I'm
great how are you finally doing this
yeah what's up fam Brian Cowen is had to
jet out so I'm doing this solo one-man
army here but also Brian doesn't need to
be here for this commercial because it's
a commercial for hair and he has
terrible hair so probably better that he
doesn't advertise this company called
hims 66% of men start to lose their hair
by age 35 once you've noticed it's
thinning it's way too late as Brian it's
one of the reason why he left the hair
line slowly starts to move backwards and
like dude what am i doing man
it's too late get on it right now
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for the borough's hims
is helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed physicians and
fda-approved products to help treat hair
loss no snake oil pills we're talking
prescription solutions backed by real
science it's so easy no more awkward
in-person doctor visits or long lines at
the pharmacies all you do is answer
quick few questions a doctor looks at it
sends it to your house will discreet
package no one needs to know all of a
sudden you show up looking like Fabio
everyone's like oh my god and you're so
happy okay you guys can get right now
you get start for five dollars right now
while supplies last and this and also
the doctor's approval see website for
full details and safety information this
could cost hundreds you went to a doctor
pharmacy somewhere else go to for hems
Tom slash fighter that's fo r hims comm
slash fighter for hams comm slash
fighter we are
so brought to you by CBS Sports HQ I
think we're all aware in sports
especially on TV nowadays it's full of
drama and hot topics and hot takes we
don't really care what people are saying
they're not really talking real sports
CBS sports HQ is here to change all that
CBS sports HQ is a network that streams
live 24/7 and they have coverage that
just focuses on the game that's what you
want to bring you the latest news
highlights previews reactions to all the
on-field action their fantasy sports
experts will give you the info you need
so you just keep making baked no fake
debates no overproduced shows no
politics just sports for real sports
fans just open up the CBS Sports app
watch anytime from anywhere on your
phone or at home on your Apple TV Roku
or fire TV it couldn't be easier
download the CBS sports app right now
and watch CBS Sports HQ today tonight
and I just remember like I was like
kicking like a telephone yeah that's
right it's like is it another level
there's a giant man he goes he's playing
a zombie in a TV show I did call Death
Valley they said you can kick me here
just really kick me cuz I'm gonna be
bent over I go okay and I go but I don't
want kake kut'r he goes he goes look at
me goes you can kick me real hard I got
and I had the call saying as I go I said
this out loud no I did I go I go I'm a
black belt in Taekwondo and he looked at
me because it's cool dude I get it I'm
sure you are I first think I kicked him
and then he goes I'm telling you the
Technica I [ __ ] kick him know
wherever he was he was just fine you
give me fights growing up Rob oh yeah is
that when I look at you I think Street
Fighter yeah that's just survival ya
know but the thing is you guys didn't
know but that you had to be when you're
smaller and also when you're also you
know it's like you got to get it over
with quick the fight either win or lose
quickly and also make sure it's in front
of as many people so there's a chance of
somebody to break it up yeah that's not
close to school make sure there's an
adult that could be within the area yeah
I had to strategize the whole time
it was like I remember like a one time
it was Bill Schulz his brother John
Schultz I remember he you know there's
something wrong with that family god
bless him but like and I remember this
one kid and I said just keep the fight
close to the school and sure enough he
waited for me to get far enough away
from the school and this is a knock-down
drag-out fight until we're both
exhausted and I had a big gigantic black
eye and they smell like how hard some
kids had hard hands yeah some kids you
could take it some kids like I remember
like cliff vanderwerff damn you remember
the name yeah I would never hit my
friend Rick Gloucester was my best
buddies we're still where'd you grow up
just right below San Francisco I grew up
in the Haight Ashbury the summer of love
was the summer of moving for us Summer
of Love I swear that we were that was at
born 1963 1967 there's like you know you
had like yeah yeah you know yeah the
whole yeah that my dad you know three
there's a bunch of crazy hippies out
there but then we move down to the but I
basically I grew up it mom was Filipino
right of yeah in Pacifica so yeah so but
I been we said cliff Randor where if I
were him his in my friend Rick said yeah
how I look is that you're okay but your
nose is over here but so you know and
like there's an about mcpeak I remember
that's a big dude I remember this guy
I just gotta wait wait get him right in
the nose do you remember yes you see say
if I pop in the nose it's over cuz then
you can't see then it's really over it's
not gonna nose you if you really want to
fight after getting hit in the nose not
me maybe you remember details like that
you know remembers night I don't have
any details my child is a complete blur
yeah my my friends said to me my buddy
goes hey you know I've known you your
whole life I know nothing about your
childhood yeah I sometimes I wonder
about it sometimes I wonder because
we're getting older is it that or but
yeah I know no I just don't memory I
just never think about my childhood that
way I remember some names but not that's
you remember negative times a lot you
know but I mean a couple of fights that
I win it's not as interesting cuz yeah
you know let it eat you yeah but I
remember like I just this one guy really
wanted to fight me I was avoiding it but
I made sure I was I stayed on the school
grounds I was walking around the school
and literally like at that time there's
hundreds of kids I'm not exact
they were just waiting for anything
tomorrow break the tedium they're so
bored it's happening yeah yep and so I
just anyway so he just he just came at
me and I couldn't back the way anymore
because there was a little bit crowd
behind me said okay here we go and then
and then I never wanted to fight though
cuz I for me I remember a kid said I'll
see you after school and for me I was
always the kid at school who like I like
everybody
my my it's just I like everybody and I'm
like I like me and the last thing I want
to do is fight I'd it's not in my thing
yeah and I remember he was big and
strong and I was probably in eighth
grade and I was like number one I don't
want to fight that guy's gonna beat me
up number two it makes me feel bad oh
yeah number three I'm [ __ ] scared if
you feel when I was bombed by cookies
you have to like it's that the thing is
your life's in danger like you mean for
professional either yeah it's like you
can't like I don't wanna hit that guys
totally I bet I don't wanna hit this guy
too hard then you can't fight anymore
right yeah well my thing is I had an
older brother who's the scariest guy in
the neighborhood so if I was having a
problem I knew I was gonna find out till
my friend like we just come we just
think a week come so if you got out of
hand
big bro was there yeah well I I knew I
wouldn't get - what bad bad cuz he would
jump he needs somebody at least in he
was now he's I don't wanna get kicked in
the head by guys that like beating on
other people there's one you called
psychopath yes there was one psycho his
older brother Tony Tony Lewis was it was
the older brother can I gather all the
names Mike Joe Louis was the younger guy
my age who was just you know like a man
at 13 yeah he really have his side
Bernie roids because hey I had to hunt
and this guy and he just wanted to beat
the [ __ ] out of everybody just it was
like I want to he said come on you could
probably beat my ass you know what you
could probably kick yeah and I was like
I knew oh you're good and I'm good I
don't need to um well they say in jail
even in jail like where did the bat is
Chronos yeah it's a very small fraction
of people that are actual Psychopaths
and super violent but they're the ones
that control everything so a lot of
times in jail you'll see like they'll
have you know people get stabbed and
stuff
that shit's being controlled by a very
small group of dudes and sometimes I'll
have these programs they like tape those
guys and just put them in they just say
they don't one you have a real most
people in jail you want to do the time
you just wanna get along if they're
actually hanging out and stuff like that
it's the sociopath
at the top that that organize and
enforce stuff like they'd sound freaking
jail is the same thing but at least
they're in jailed it's a sociopath
outside of jail that you worried yeah
that's the problem yeah and sometimes
they can be did you suppose you're
interested in that self does it mean to
me I think if you get too interested in
a specific thing it's you're creating
that kind of my pain I mean yeah I think
there's something to that my mother says
that my mother says stop I I get I get
very upset about the injustice in the
world right yes so for those of you I
would read about the Congo and I'd read
about what they were doing to office and
I would I would I couldn't sleep I would
have to I would have to put myself to
bed thinking about being in a helicopter
gunship and opening up on all the
soldiers because of what they do I want
Joseph Kony and those pieces of [ __ ] my
mother would say you need to stop this
it's bad for your health and she's right
you have to like you know what the thing
is about it I'm glad you brought that up
because you have to kind of do in life I
think is you're never gonna figure it
all out but you need kind of a beachhead
you need to have some sort of
interpretation of what this whole
experience is in life yes in some way to
live a decent life and not go crazy yes
and you can find the luggage so funny
you find the negativity you could fight
it's there but but at the same time you
have to find a balance of it and that's
why I like Buddhism for me is like the
middle well you don't get too out too
low because there has to be some of that
you if you didn't know if there wasn't
bad you wouldn't know what good was well
I like Buddhism and I like the idea that
this might all be a simulation
I like the idea they know that's where
it's uh well I like that
I think that's potential narcissism in
the thinking that it's that it's just
this this thing it doesn't really exist
where it's fake or it's all of it
because then it don't give you an excuse
to not behave well that I don't want no
what I actually like to think about is I
believe in a higher power I always have
believed sharing something Evelyn or the
idea that there's a good way in a bad
way which which and so I think that
religion and faith and love and hope
have very powerful roles to play in our
lives so so what I would I had explained
to me recently was the idea that we
might already be in so listen to this
idea what's gonna blew my mind what's
also a native thinking when we may
already be some replicating machines our
biological heritage may be
long-dead the idea might be this is this
is this is kind of this new this is what
Elon Musk and so yeah let's talk about
so as we are now we're human beings and
we're creating computers in our likeness
if you actually extrapolate far enough
we are gonna reverse engineer the brain
we are gonna come up with a robot that
is this human-like as it gets the
question is can you create consciousness
can you create a machine that actually
knows it's gonna die whatever it might
be and if that's the case then it will
will it make will it make a machine
that's even more sophisticated than it
if you keep following that it folds in
on itself and we may already be the
product of that early Star Trek episode
I don't buy into it it's also depressing
- yes it's pressing but it also makes me
feel like there's got to be some higher
designer some higher gods I would just
think that you know look Alan Watts
talks about this in a really interesting
way and he said look let's get this
straight right now if there is such a
thing as compassion and kindness and
love then it's endemic of a universe
that creates it because that's what
we're from so let's get that straight
right now so he says yeah and so I do
think that I also think that hey you
know we got to be very careful going
down the road like we have everything
figured out every time to do that things
get completely [ __ ] up like for
instance we are already like when they
say you know we're half the man our
grandfather was it's because the sperm
count is down to like 50% and just like
the last 40 years less than 40 years so
there is like there's a real chance that
you know there were self that were we're
that didn't make sense as we get more
and more crowded than our sperm counts
get lower because nature kind of goes
creative tremendous I know did you read
that book of course I don't read but I
like oh yeah I've you heard have you
heard the book on audiotape sapiens do
yeah yeah yeah twice that but yeah thank
you
it's just like I listen to I didn't read
it yeah yeah yeah where's the time we're
losing our drive I do one thing what you
could do like three thing have you
listened that book I have the book I'm
very very like cornets so almost
I know I have so many books that I have
so many but that is so like if you're
right there it's like I got it I'm
almost there are you practically with us
but the idea is you know the thing about
it's like you me tell stories and they
go around you ever do that when you're
looking at stories the same thing with
like books on tape you know you don't
even need to hear the book anymore just
hear us to tell 30 sec I'm always a TED
talk I'll wait for the Ted yeah
then I regurgitate almost a but the idea
is by the way okay the idea of it is is
just to and by the way you don't have to
practice that's another thing about it
too but Buddhism thing how long have you
been well you know I got into Buddhism
or just I remember like the first time I
was aware of it was like when I was a
little little boy yes like not quite
eight years old in Japan and my parents
you know it took one of those little
cheapy tours where you go here spend one
night in a horrible hotel and do this
and whatever but my mom's Filipino and
that's what went sour relatives in the
Philippines that was the first time I
was exposed to like incredible poverty
poverty yes like poverty like I didn't
even know what poverty was I was at
seven years old II it kind of saw this
there was another way of like my dad
would get mobbed if he gave like some
money to a little kid the next you know
with the kids would just come out and
mob them and I realized these kids are
working already and they're my age how I
grew up and so when you see that you
just it just changed you and then one of
the places we went to went to Japan and
I remember there was this you know every
place there's there's a these temples
and it says well this has the hair of
Buddha in here this has a fingernail
this has like a stick that he used I
mean I guess if you put it all together
you'd create like there'd be ten
thousand Buddha's you know but so the
idea is there was this they said this is
the Buddha he's encased in gold and he
basically said if my body stays intact
for 72 for 72 days after I pass away
then encase me in gold because
everything I told you is true and I
remember thinking wow somehow he was
able to tell I just remember being as a
little boy thing somehow he was able to
get himself in his body and telling
himself to to maintain even after his
death in some way and I didn't know even
think about cellular level or what I'm
trying to be funny here but why is the
Buddha like a fat guy
why is he fat he said you know where the
Buddha anybody know what where the
Buddha originally came from yes is from
India
thank not who's an Indian prince but the
idea has him no that's that's a
rendition that's only in sites like our
white Jesus yeah the siddhartha gautama
was that was a prince and in fact the
buddha was if you really study his life
he was actually at one point he was
living on a handful of Rice's right he
said that husband was booze and Buddhism
was reformed in China and China Chinese
reformed Buddhism because Buddhism in
his original is in in my understanding
of its original incarnation because
again it's not like a Bible Buddhism
doesn't have like it's a written it's
it's an oral thing it's it's it's a
basically with a man and and Zen
Buddhism is even more attract more of a
sect yeah so basically what happened was
the Chinese reformed Buddhism and said
you didn't have to be isolated like you
know like the the original Buddhist
monks in India they would have their own
temples they would have their own places
they were locked off from the world and
the Chinese reformed Buddhism in a
really good way by saying you could be
married you should be a Buddha in the
world not outside they have an influence
in it and and be challenged in as many
ways you can't having kids having a
doing things and being a part of that
but still being the middle way and also
like and drinking you know somewhat like
in when I was in in Taiwan you know
you'd meet some you know Buddhists and
they they drink they drink and it's like
you know is they actually say if you
have a drink before you meditate you
save you six months program or further
progress and Alan watch you can just
tell he was a drinker he was done was
that was a Cosmo man who studied the
brain and a scientist and was also a gay
power lifter at least I mean he was like
he was incredible and he had brought
Transcendental Meditation to the West so
he was a really incredible were you
Buddhist when you were doing Saturday
night life no I mean I kind of shifted
in and out of it you know and I think
you take the take a little bit of
everything Christianity XY's what I'm
swinging back to as well now you're
swinging back to Christianity yeah I am
I really do think cuz I think
Christianity is getting attacked and any
any religion that's getting attacked I
go there must be something to this yeah
you know so that I think so too
again I I think I'm like
Buddhism is not a religion it's not a
it's not a philosophy you have to
describe it by what it isn't and that's
really interesting to me
I wish we look down right now you're not
even sitting you're actually floating
like just an inch off well I think again
what we're going back to is what you're
talking about is having a some sort of
philosophy or a fundament of
foundational thinking so you don't go
crazy so you can may that make sense of
the world and everybody's trying to have
that and that's the weird thing is is if
you question somebody else's belief
system if they go apeshit I know and
that's what you have like normal people
like I mean one of the guys who would
just lost his [ __ ] the other day who
I've met he's an actor who just when I
was attacking other other people who
were representing like another you know
are you talking about [ __ ] Debra
Messing and Eric yeah and I was like
these are normal nice people but they
just what happens is again that's why
like again Buddhism is the middle way
try to stay in the middle yeah and
they'll just swing out and and I guess
what happens is I think their belief
structures getting to the point where
you know that it's getting knocked and
and they're getting questioned to it and
they get nasty yeah but also I'm happy
yeah a minute what's funny about someone
like eric mccormack you probably know
i've met him it was like a great nice
guy but he's not probably not i think he
needs to pick up a history book because
when you when you say let's create a
list my friend yeah it's a matter of
time before you're on a list oh yeah we
don't want to live in a society like
this especially when you have a
political one of you you have a right to
well you have a actual censorship now a
hundred percent in hollywood i mean the
big tech Google and stuff I mean I'm not
a big fan of all the right-wing not as
conspiracy or just you know put your
left wing but there you can't the idea
shadow band yes the idea of that of
disagreement shouldn't go to destruction
a personal destruction career trying to
take somebody's career away as they hey
you know what this guy said and whatever
it's canceled culture cancel cut so you
have that um you should when you when
you disagree you should go right to
debate not decide Roy not to mean you
should go in to dissuade use your muse
your ideas against my idea but with an
open mind yes and it's but I think
people like Eric McCormack Debra Messing
by the way I have
I don't talk about badly about anybody
publicly he like you I've never heard
anything good like you never heard
anything but negative things about Debra
Messing so she and she's just not a nice
person from what I've just know too many
people to work with her but but there I
said something bad about somebody but
but um but I took a lot though for you
say that she's just not an option and
but at the end of the day um I think
that these are people are not confident
in their own ideas use your ideas pit
them against the other ideas and let's
see what comes out on top use your ideas
don't censor people anywhere their
career don't censor anyone because I do
think though you know the interesting
part about it what I got from sapience
was that people really don't change that
much Oh think about it it was something
very stunning and I'm gonna kind of
steal it and at the same time you know
murder on my own but it's like if you
were born in 1900 okay you guys know
that before World War one before there
was you know transportation you know
in 1903 I guess with the first plane
really the Wright brothers right but if
you're born in 1904 mning culture right
mostly agrarian so you're talking 80% of
Americans were farmers okay and that's
why when World War one came that was a
really far away let's not we don't want
anything to do with that and so but if
you live to be 69 years old you landed
on the [ __ ] moon yeah so but the
people haven't changed they haven't
progressed and in their mind and in
their thinking they haven't progressed
at that point so you thinking for now
you go fifty years later to like to us
and it still hasn't changed that much
more so you have these people who are
very kind of tribal very provincial
still and so the Internet's allowed you
to create your own tribe - the first
time has allowed you to really purify
your echo chamber well because you can
get people to jump in and that's what we
in the bandwidth right [ __ ] like let's
get them like oh yeah let's get here
that's what ski talks about it's like
the idea of the Internet is amazing
because you have the potential to learn
things and to get out there and open up
your your scope to the world and the
encyclopedia is at your fingertips
however people just go to the same [ __ ]
over and over again the only stuff that
their interest yes so it does become
like you said an echo chamber yeah but
the potentiality is there and I would
just say this the people who are like
who have liked it the problem when you
turn 50 is like I never wanted to be the
guy who's like when you get in your 50s
ago I
we were kids oh yeah we attend
conversation yeah no people in their 50s
when I was 15 we're complaining about
[ __ ] is but so there's a kind of of a
cycle that happens however I would just
say this if you look at any new industry
if you look at anything new that changes
the world that has an impact on the
world you take a look at well let's take
a VA ssin this is my example I use in
1903 when it started to go 15 years in
which is roughly 15 years of social
media where it's been is so impactful
right if you go 15 years into an
aviation is invented and then to where
in in 1918 they were just starting to
figure out how to kill people with
planes yeah so now we and then it took a
while for it to become mass trans mass
transportation and become a peaceful
mostly peaceful use so if you look at 15
years into social media they're just
figuring how to kill people with it
maybe we're just figuring out how toxic
it is and how then companies that made
them have made it so your brain has the
impulse same impulses gee I've had a
storm yeah but you can do what you can
do though is that you can you can become
aware of it and then I think people will
will survive this yeah and then get to a
place of peacefulness with it but it's
all still new I mean it's incredible I
mean it's like I don't know if Einstein
really said that thing about when you
know when our communication exceeds our
ability to when our technology exceeds
our ability to communicate we'll have a
generation of idiots or some some he's
not long derivation of that yeah I have
a tattoo you can't that's here if you I
brought I can't read that no [ __ ] if you
drive by it like a school now high
school or middle school if none of them
I talk to each other all of them are
waiting for the bus looking at the front
results to all those crazy lot of adults
yep when you see like your kid comes up
to you and you're on your phone your
kids trying to get your attention you go
there hey dude when I come into my house
Howell Jack isn't like this I'm like hey
Dad
Rob lg6 and - oh yeah dude I want ya I
went back I want that let's do this
again I love it yeah well you're going
to I have eight and eleven I have a
thirty year old - oh you do oh damn yeah
oh she you've been down this road yeah
and I found the mistake
say I missed too much from the 30 year
old I did miss you so much because you
were busy like shooting their life I was
an idiot but I was divorced and like I
just you know I didn't I didn't spend
enough time with her and I really pay
I'm you know what the thing is it your
relationship that you have and I'm and
god bless her my daughter Elle King
she's a great musician name she's a
great musician and she's just a great
kid
and she's opening for uh she was just
opened she just played the Hollywood
Bowl oh what a night seriously opening
for heart Wow
and she's an incredible musician but her
name al king okay but I'm saying that
like I you know you don't want third if
she's 30 you're 50 yes you had her when
you're 20 I'm 55 so you had only had 25
yeah I mean no but there's no who's
gonna get it right when you're 25 I'm
saying last 25 I could barely take care
of a plant but she ended up becoming an
artist and and expressing yourself and
she's just a great kid and maybe she's
an adult now she's always been an artist
always been out she was just trying to
find some touch that she loved and she
could show her passion for and she did
it she was on American Idol yeah that's
where I know her from and she's doing
really good CT might pass that was a
long time ago and I remember from the
American Idol huh and she's killing
right now and I'm happy for and you know
what though she's very been so generous
to like you know have me in her life and
and I you know she's such a great big
sister to her two little sisters awesome
but I do know that like you know it's
just the times that you miss you never
get back so much Nevison how old your
kids though 8 and 11 oh you're right in
it that's the best I can have a three
and a half year old I have another one
on the way in November all right two
boys beautiful yeah
I know it's my son my daughter now at
eleven is already rolling her eyes at me
my son still eight and he's still such a
sweetie I told him a story yesterday I
make up these stories about this
enchanted forest and how when I was in
nature camp and I kind of put myself in
the story the questions yes did the
monkeys take you into the trees would
they look like III [ __ ] lasa I Google
chim hairless chimpanzee and and and he
and he basically they have you ever seen
that chimp with no hair on it they're
the most terrifying Oscars and he goes
if he goes that exist I go yeah
what are you doing dude took me into the
trees and they were playing catch with
me what how did you get that's what I
brought up that's what I brought up yes
they're there nine times far they have
nine times more of the bone density than
we do
yeah their ratio of like adrenaline ours
at the most goes from like zero to one
there's goes from like zero to 11 oh so
they that's why and they're stronger
than so that's why you a chimpanzee can
drop three stories from on to cement and
just walk it off what yeah that's how
strong you know your if they rip your I
had to work with them in a movie and I
said I want to learn something
beforehand oh really I went down at the
LA Zoo and they said okay if you're
gonna work with these guys just never
turn your back on Dave and he said what
never turn your back and I said just
don't ever turn your back on me said why
and he did this to me well I said I
would see that guy right there but taken
Karen for 18 18 18 years I've been you
know wiping his ass giving him food
every day I turned my back at him one
time he did this to me and he looked up
he's missing a finger oh bit my finger
off then there's a guy who area is there
there that's a picture I brought up man
that's her that's her ah that was the
animal back like 19
so anyways enjoy that enjoy that look
those hands built for cruelty just bill
to rip you to shreds yes that's good
there's another thing there's another
guy who's working listen I was work with
the chimpanzee you can only work with
them until they become like get their
incisors and become like adults because
you can't work them after that because
they want to take you out and that's
right the other guy out so you can only
work it so it's not a good idea to work
with wild animals and I wouldn't do it
again no you don't work with adult
chimps
no ukb remember when we've done a high
one we're shooting that comedy show and
work with I work with Louie who was the
the orangutan and this is his handler
who work with his chimpanzee he told me
this story he said well let me tell this
one story he says so I was with this you
know chimpanzee and he was like you know
ten like not quite 11 years old and he
liked to ride in the car in my pickup
truck on my shoulders and he said then
I'm driving we're driving back to the
you know the place and then all of
sudden I felt this warm liquid rolling
coming down my my neck into my chest and
I look over and it's blood and I go and
he you bit my ear off so he said it was
everything I could do he's like my elbow
that's it he's my elbow I was punching
him as hard as I could agreement
punching and punching and that barely
was able to get out and I had to keep
the door closed because he would have
come out if he would have got out I
ripped fairly able to well he would have
ripped somebody else's face do you
remember that lady who was on like
ripped her face off that lady was on
Maury she was sleeping with this
literally sleeping with him in a ropes
you give him like xanax oh yeah and wine
oh I'm sorry
stem glasses with red wine taking bass
with him and then like reading to him I
give him poison
one day she has like a guy friend coming
like no gasps the kalam Inger so I was a
gal no it was a guy no it was a warning
guy he's a woman she changed and what
happened was she changed he was a
200-pound male chimp great joyful full
fully grown bull the girl he had changed
she had changed her hairstyles I did
when I got her hair done and that chimp
star and went hominid your face no he
ripped her face that's right what they
do first is this is I it's like a fight
he said well I'm gonna do things so
first of all I'm gonna buy it off I'm
gonna buy it off all your fingers so you
don't have a chance to poke my eye out
for a sec and then I'm gonna bite off
then I'm gonna take off your jaw so you
can't bite me back and then I'm gonna
bite off your nuts so you know this is
serious that's literally what they do
cuz the John faith is like I said the
John face didn't do it the nuts didn't
do it they need to be like hey at that
point but champ wins let's jump a second
let's find very seriously
unbelievable well there's that great
show fatal attraction on fatal
attraction on the animal planet or one
of those which says if these idiots that
take wild animals is a I'm gonna live
with a snake Python and is that he loves
me he's sleeping next to me the Python
sleeping he's also stretching all the
way he's like he's measuring you to
[ __ ] eat you look exactly what he's
doing dum-dum what he's doing somebody
had like a komodo dragon you know and
every day he was like he'd lick me lick
me and he pulls please poisoning you
poisoning you slowly slowly slow and
then eventually ate him and kill him the
guy you got to watch the show fatal
tracks you never seen it no I know what
you're gonna do you're gonna watch this
and then you're gonna stay up till five
o'clock in the morning you're not to be
able to stop watching
that's tough fatal attraction to slay
those tech by that chimpanzee she know
she can't what's not she came to see she
came to see her friend my friend
so as the owner to has that well no as
the chip is he eating the just the
legislating so I check this out as the
chip is eating killing her she stabbed
him with a knife and he loved the owner
yes because what do you do then the cop
go and shot that chimp three times in
the chest and the chimp still climbed up
on top of the roof and then then then
they unloaded on him a bunch of other
times and he finally died with three
slugs from a from a nine-millimeter and
the chimp was like I'm good I'm gonna
climb this I'm gonna climb I'm still
gonna climb the [ __ ] house yeah no no
this you're a touch one cuz I've held
the chimp I know he's chimp they're made
of wood their muscles are wooden now I
remember cuz this one guy was one you
know nine year old orangutan he was
working with in that movie the animal he
was like the first day he like me guy
was a new thing the second day he was
bored of me already
and I remember cuz yeah this one series
is and round my throat and he was just
like literally like this hand was like
iron and he just started squeezing my
throat am I gonna [ __ ] die right now
probably yeah I don't like primates
well no it's they just it's another
level and like you have to like push me
up I'm telling you they're bone
densities 9 times more than us but it's
the exact density is 9 times 9 and their
adrenaline level can go up I think it's
11 times more than us so that like you
know the fight-or-flight yeah yeah so
they're vine so we combined that bone
density and that muscular you know and
try right and you combine that with like
this this is like you know this is
something that's swinging
vines and trees think of think about a
200 or you know 200 pound male chimp
like what that would do well there's
also like there's 400 pounds in the
congo sir yeah big boys in the Congo
yeah they call them the leopard you
don't see one living on the grill I
don't look them in the eye when you go
out to my friend I do I do you guys
remember you're the baboon that do that
that does not to look him in the eye my
friend went out yeah don't look em in
the eye my friend went out there it's
like I just be called Rhodesia
country now again Bob we're now okay he
say so he went out there and you could
go out there and they're these Plains
guerrillas they're out in the you know
and so this like the last group of them
left and they people visitors go out
then you pay money which is great
because instead of these guys who would
normally be killing these beautiful
mountain lowland mountain laurel israel
yeah yes you could do a tour and it
actually pays for the park pays to
maintain and pays to protect these
animals and so it's it's really a good
thing to go do when you go out there
they tell you there's certain behavior
you do not do you don't stare
you know the silverback yeah yeah don't
[ __ ] with this silver I'm not going on
that tour you all just give you the
moment here's over back pain here enough
but here's a communication you said you
go out they said why said my friend
chattels night he said he went out there
you know he said so what do you do is
well you know they don't look him in the
eye and you sit down and you just let
him know you're okay and they tell him
there's an mmm-hmm it's like I'm just
everything's cool and he'll give it back
to you you ever see that video where
that where the mountain gorillas the big
male just walks by the one of the guides
and grabs him by the ankle and just
takes them for a little dragged you see
that bring that up Mountain lie mountain
gorilla so that they're watching a troop
in the Congo there are there all these
naturalist and they're on there it's
like you can pay to do this and you're
all like this they're all staying there
they're really quiet and this giant male
comes walking by grabs the [ __ ]
by by his Hankel and just takes him for
a little Drive that's a combi with the
head huh
yeah well that's the thing it's like
what really grabs the man out of nowhere
if you guys don't done maybe the problem
with people in California is they don't
really realize that there's another rest
of the country out there and that's why
you get your Debra Messing's and stuff
is like it is another country out there
and it's like you leave 45 minutes
outside any big city it gets a little
weird
and like you have this look whoa what is
that like a napping
no he's lying down try to be cool yeah
that's what you do it's like a man whoa
but like you like there for instance you
probably don't know this but there are
5,000 lions it privately owned by people
in the United States
love and how much you know but yeah [ __ ]
well I you ask me it's a terrible lie to
everybody because they outgrow just like
you know when you used to have like
people used to have like little turtles
which like have like hepatitis A in
there I know you got one L anxious yeah
you know but we had them all over the
plaint turtles stuff and then you know
some places they'll get like you can buy
an alligator you know you have an
alligator and obvious gets too big let's
get rid of this damn alligator well
there are the problems in the 70s and
before they pass it you could buy Nile
crocodiles for like just yet it goes
through three hoops and buy them so
Tommy's in Florida would have here's a
cry now Gregor all sudden is now
crocodile gets to be not more than five
feet and it'll it'll bite everything
don't think I let's put it in the
Everglades well they have a problem
Columbia right cuz well Escobar had like
hippos and nothing like real crocodile
but I have this now in the Everglades
they have like Burmese pythons yeah you
try to sneak in like a lemon or an
orange into that they'll build will tilt
cast you'll they'll tackle you at the
airport yeah but if you try to stand
what are you got in the bag there it is
that what is that a is that Burmese
python all right bring it in just make
sure it [ __ ] everything out there so
what happened was during Hurricane
Andrew was when that you know people
just abandon their homes and the roofs
got blown off and a couple of these
Burmese pythons got out there and each
one of those is able to lay like 200 300
eggs so you have like a Burmese you put
up Burmese right on a treating alligator
problem yeah look at Bernie's Python so
don't mess with Florida I don't go into
anybody's of water so here's what you
got you got 40-foot pythons out there
that are literally they'll eat an
alligator or and then and then out and
then the alligator will rip it and
explode it so these are like it's
incredible it's not these two animals
are never supposed to meet
well they got Nile crocodiles they think
they're in their water from Florida
because they got they got loose handlers
couldn't take care of them and just let
them loose in the Everglades Wow and
they have had and if you can look it up
they have found some Nile
Salty's in the Everglades that's a
disaster art nightmare dangerous is a
danger look at that right there it's
unbelievable
so they go hunting now you can get like
a tag and you can go Python hunting
that's out in the Everglades
it's gonna cool I mean I'm like I won't
feel bad about that at all I'm not but
like if you're gonna you know I mean
this is that animal should not be there
they have to get that but depopulate
that Harriet look
unbelievable well that's a thing to
Florida Florida is always the weird [ __ ]
happens it's in Florida you know some
weird it's always in Florida no guy
who's you know the homeless guys face
remember that story guy got homeless
guys got a space eatin yeah you know
Imagi feel sorry for the homeless guys
hey he's a naked guy running towards me
yeah you know it's it
what if you can what is he water I
wonder what he wants maybe he's gonna
try to [ __ ] me well whatever I have been
[ __ ] a long time you know what to get
though he's eating my face I did not see
this coming
it's it's coming but because Florida
because look at that yeah I don't know
if that's real now Gabriel it's not that
I don't but it's still a good picture
I'm glad somebody took the time to do
that that's like a whole lot to ever did
that
definitely photocell either lady yeah
but there is a funny there there's the I
love the year but that's still pretty
big I don't give a [ __ ] that woman's
fake or not throw a huge that yeah still
huge snake yeah that is nuts
no but anyway I mean I I like I love
nature but I like at the same time like
for me at this point in my life I like
you know safari you think I'd like a
four seasons on the edge of the Safari
I'm there you know Rob yeah man it's so
true I just like true I don't want to
like get bit by some suit suit fly and
then the next thing you know and like
malaria just friends had malaria three
times I when I was in South Africa they
had we went on a very nice sophisticated
Safari yeah on what used to be an old
cattle farm and then we we had dinner in
the bush
meaning we pulled up and they had
beautiful tents lined up and these are
wild animals around they were cooking
the bet yes and they guys with guns but
yeah and they were cookie on your new
day they were cooking the best the best
antelope and kudu oh yeah yeah oh my god
these cooks were incredible and we had a
sophisticated wild game I had no desire
to do that wine I have no desire to do
that pros cons pros they're working and
you go like ways to Safari 45 minutes
okay so I go there for two hours I come
back to my hotel I said I got that you
know but I do think like like that going
back to the book the sapiens
there is like the reason why there's
like so many billions of us is I don't
know if there's eight billion human
beings now it's because they were able
to at one point not
just bejust hunter-gatherers but you're
able to like they had those people doing
that and they had these people building
and then we're able to like you know
that was the great nation states by
growing your own food and domesticated
cattle yeah but that's what happened
like why Australia had never happened
why the the native peoples who
originally there they had these four
hundred pound birds which are basically
cattle if they would have just got him
together and kept him in a barn then
they could have had like you have to
have like groups of people this would be
the priests these will be the merchants
these would be the and then you get hey
you know we can also do now we can free
up these people they can go kill those
other people over there and we can take
their [ __ ] yeah and their women or
whatever yeah and so that's that's kind
of the whole iid well they have their
they have emus and they have caste you
Ares I think right yeah very dangerous
bird the other second one cast cast
yours you said that's the dangerous
that's the real dangerous whoa those are
not as dangerous but they can still hurt
you
yeah but they're not cast you Ares is a
very so what happened was they killed
almost 400 pound birds into the were
extinct the same thing like when the
Asiatic people came over to to the
United States the Oh Monday nights it
doesn't mean what an idiot went when he
came over to cross the the Bering Strait
the Bering Strait yeah they came over
when a really low sea level Ice Age
whatever and they came over the first
thing they do is they wiped out like
these giant sloths because that was like
a giant piece of meat right there
basically it just looked at you really
slowly is like you know had no defense
because I had never had any no one's
killed him yeah yeah you know so um
first thing to go so there was like
there were you can actually see their
eyes was actually a giant lion that was
in I was a North American lion that was
one of the huge yeah the biggest one
baby though then I wasn't it was like a
cross between a bear and I'll lie it was
basically an inline bring up bring up
that bring up that and a saber-toothed
cat at the you know I think the
saber-toothed cat what happens well they
started killing the prey of those and
then they started killing them and they
couldn't make it but if those teeth were
so it didn't see an appropriate yeah it
didn't some saber-tooth it's so
basically that was to show off to the
other ones it didn't seem like it was
very fun now there was another were
hunting the woolly mammoth right that's
the ad that was the Americas they're
lion that giant geez what is that thing
right so it was that was what
wreaked havoc that that Lattimore left
yeah that that retailers it was like
well that it was a shorter snout in a
much bigger lion it was like the size of
a [ __ ] bear and that caused major
problems for the for the people for the
humans who came it sucks those aren't
around anymore yeah or well well well
you sucks for the people who are yeah
I'm sure that that was like no but
because see there were no Nate if there
were no native peoples like being sad
when those guys went away so there's no
more of those things eating less yeah
there you go
Wow American lion there it is yeah and
so that's probably one out about
thirteen thousand years ago
that's this great thing is that the La
Brea Tar Pits here and there's you know
it's just a working museum a fight it's
still finding like pits of animals so
it's the thing about Los Angeles it has
had the best weather for the last thirty
thousand years so every mammal that
could make it that you know whether they
wanted to be a star or not if you were
at saber-toothed cat you want you to get
the LA and and that's why they found
these incredible finds of like mostly
wolves and predators yeah because these
animals would get stuck in this lens
polluting our and the eyes food right
there and then and then they get stuck
and so yeah murabbi got all this from
that sapiens book no get about 20 pages
I'll remember any of this [ __ ] the Brea
Tar Pits you go there it's not in LA
it's great but so yeah so when did that
become extinct that one uh I'd believe
this like even even Australia had like a
lion
they had like a lion that marsupial lion
they call him our soup real tiger yeah
so have you kept its young aunt Pam yeah
and that the last one that's they killed
them all and then last one died like
1937 marsupial tiger a little bit up I
heard some gun arm dog Jack Shepards
podcast saying elephants you know their
trunks yeah yeah they came from a
because they used to be underwater
animals whales whales are are of course
we related to hippos I know so well
whales to me like it's a sea cow would
you think that was make sense right so
we go in while of the water whales or
sea cows basically there it is right
there yeah that's as many as I think er
the things extinct yeah that was the
last one it was a beautiful animal now
you're not really hot afraid of that I
mean
like you're like F [ __ ] off you know you
said a swift kick to the face you know
rub there like a possum you they look at
it a little wiry because that was the
they're like it's not the end of the
world that they went away
if Tigers run away like no but those are
look at that mouth look at that mouth
right there yes a wolf but anyway I know
I think that the diversification of the
planet is important to keep that going
because episode keeps us going
well so when they introduce wolves back
in the Yellowstone yeah it's pretty
amazing because it has created changed
actually changed the river water yeah
yeah because because they started
killing the elk and the elk stopped
eating as much vegetation and that gave
other animals more time to produce and I
think the the the the Beavers more to
chew on and create the plants and trees
it's like a small ladies cycle of life
those little trees all of a sudden get
to grow and it daily changes their the
scientists who talked about this and
proved it wants to bring lions back to
Europe and everything all I do take it
whoa we can't have prides of lions in
will because you haven't in like the
Santa Monica Mountains here we have like
outline you have to understand you have
the Cougars that we have here but for
one cougar they need to have about 200
miles literally of yes range so you're
not gonna have too many otherwise that's
what happens otherwise they can't
survive I see so new that mountain line
that it's been around forever one of the
bigger ones just got hit on the 405
passed away it's a shame it did cross
the 405 well there you go that's it
because they're trying to build a bridge
of last pro/5 so the mount lights can
make it across to the mountains and I
get a hit this one was impatient that's
well yeah that's a shame it's a
beautiful animal that one looks pretty
crazy so damn it but that what I found a
car like Monte x70 or something so
amazing though yeah I mean I don't know
how they survived like those fires which
are so brutal I know you know P 61 P 61
passed away try to cross some small
Buddha that's such a bummer yeah for all
fives a bummer man he's only four years
old yeah it's just uh you know you want
to have as much I mean it is beautiful
wildlife and what what when you can keep
of it you should try it it's kind of
crazy and live that close to civil
we have a lion up although they track
him there's a ton of them over there
it's rusted where I live in the one we
hike yeah
now there's news that there's always
that like a kind of a billboard where
people see mountain lions okay I don't
think the mountain lions are important
then like that's why the wolves coming
back because it's like is the Coyotes
which are getting bigger and bigger yeah
you know they're they know
wolves kill the Coyotes though yeah in
Yellowstone and that's beautiful - yeah
cuz then there's more rabbits there's
more beavers there's more you know where
I'm at the Coyotes about every like 3:00
4:00 in the morning you hear I'm going
yeah like yelling out and they're doing
a roll call yeah they're all chairs out
there get some moves out there wolves
take make short work them cow I don't
want to laugh either let's get some
wolves out grey wolves won't bother
great well is I try to reintroduce um
where's the next place they want to
reintroduce the Wolves nave reintroduced
him in 23 states I think now or like
they're trying to bring it to Colorado
that's the new one yeah really yes we
have enough problems no I don't know the
China it's gonna help be homes Lee's
your anti nature you know what dude he's
antidepressant Oh me Rob your anti
diversity no Radwanska commas with me in
Florida infest what we were gonna kill
anacondas well I would have no problem
doing that but but I do think that the
wolf reintroduction will be very helpful
for everything it's in Colorado by the
way can we talk prove that can we talk a
little bit about what you're up to now
that you Adam Sandler Adam Sandler yes
couldn't be more relevant you're in his
movies you guys are very close yes and
but what are you doing right now let's
talk about that well thank you well I am
you know what's so funny is like for me
it's like I'm trying to figure out what
I really want to do now you know it's
like before he didn't really have like
you know there's so many options and
choices and things is like good Lord so
we started my wife and I started a
podcast you know and just let's just do
this and these conversations that we
have with each other we can just let
other people it listen to so what's
called see what happens which is based
on see what happens is that mothers my
mother like my whole child my mother's
Asian I'm most Filipino your wife's
Hispanic my wife's Hispanic my whole
childhood my mother is like every
Filipino heard that you see what happens
it's just basically that's why the
Asians are successful you know just
because it's very controlling the pair
expect you like I would get like you
know to get good grades get straight A's
if I go so what that's what you're
supposed to do that's your job what do
you want a cookie you know you do what
you're supposed to do you don't hear me
going and cooking cleaned all day what
do I get
you do your job I do my job to keep this
relationship nice and cold right cold
and then so you see what happens you
fell down see what happens you'll hurt
yourself see what happened you broke
that see what happens and once I were
playing basketball about three miles
away from the house somebody twisted an
ankle I was injured so that's called
your mom what happens you leave your
phone on see what you're doing Brian's
podcast see what happens so that's we're
doing that and we started doing that
it's been fun and they're trying to
figure out what um what the project
gonna probably do figure out a movie to
do you get a call from Sandler
periodically right you just be like hey
dude I want you to be in my movie like
take Tim Meadows you know all those guys
did they'll just get a call sometimes
yeah he don't love about him I don't
know Sandler I've met him once I did a
reading with him
I love him because he's so [ __ ] loyal
to his friends I don't know but he's all
my top five most influential people and
I would just tell you the stars he's the
reason I started one of the reason I
started stand-up yeah I remember David
Spade and I weren't talking for a while
I don't know what happened I just said a
joke about him in Phoenix or whatever
and then and I swear to God
Adam Sandler wrote it he didn't get
credit for writing it cuz of other
people rewrote it or whatever but he
made Benchwarmers and hired the two of
us so we'd have to work together for two
months
and work it out and we did and we
wouldn't friends ever since oh cool so
but like they're just a stupid [ __ ] that
you go through when you're in your late
30s whatever I'm but his choice you get
older just yeah just like what am I
worried he's not matter you know
remember and I like it but yeah I
remember like one time on that movie
there was a guy I was guy talking like
that like a [ __ ] thick Boston accent
and I'm [ __ ] yeah you know this guy
is [ __ ] guy you know and I just
walked over and I said okay I didn't
know it was an actor I know he's a
comedian probably but I said okay what
nice thing did you do Adam Sandler when
he was 19 that bet he remembered you for
and put you on this movie he can he said
let me tell you [ __ ] what there's a
[ __ ] bowling alley and we were
[ __ ] working this young [ __ ] kid
Adam Sandler and I said look pal
got a [ __ ] you know just get your
five minutes together and make sure that
[ __ ] kills and then you [ __ ] get
that like Lenny Lenny Clark is in your
life who is that Monica me but it
basically like the same yeah and you
[ __ ] put that together and then next
thing you know you're getting your [ __ ]
together and you [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
before you start doing your twenty kick
a [ __ ] five pow great that's about as
good as Southie as I've heard so and you
and Adam met on Saturday life no we were
we were a comic friends I was like he
was like a young like 19 or 20 year old
New York comic and I heard of him
and then I got on David Letterman when I
was really young but I really didn't
have him Rob did you start in North oh
that's we started like a if you don't
move out of there early it's over
you got to send that ten today I said
that their their dues if when I was in
New York yeah I saw guys hanging around
the comedy club and I go hi I'm never
going you're gonna be here forever I
gotta get the [ __ ] out here see the pit
you know it's like hey it's like they've
got their fans and it's working it's
comfortable to get a nice place they can
either one of the guys one night one of
those lifers looked at me like this like
you're in jail he I'm or he waved he was
waving in the direction of what he
thought was that way and he goes you you
you got positive energy go to LA go to
hell I said get out of here forgot like
Cobb's and punchline is that word
absolutely I just mind that all the best
guys came through there but you learn
from him like and Jerry Seinfeld's
warning on one of the greatest and like
he would come by and he would like tell
us well hey you guys you gotta click on
swearing out what take the swearing out
what did ya you take the swearing out if
it's not funny without the swearing but
it's not funny yeah so take it out and
see if it works you can't do that on TV
this is like 1984 you know and then you
see guys in like you know Jay Leno would
come by and he was the nicest guy and I
remember like it was a manager who I had
was actually a heroin addict at the time
great guy he's still alive thank God to
get over to but like he said you go pick
him up
you take him you pick up make sure
you're there on time this before like we
had before the internet before ways we
had Thomas gasps Thomas guy Thomas guy
baby and they say you had to know where
you're going luck - I knew San Francisco
I was like a street rat so I knew my way
around does it just make sure make sure
you take him to his radio show make sure
you take them to the gig make sure you
are there on the airport what was the
Jim Hobbs
no no
no he was at that time you know he's
don't like any well he was on Letterman
going wait what's your beef J hey became
my beef you don't need to get a
guillotine you might be anything and
that was his thing he started selling
out
he went from clubs to like theaters so I
was picking when I drove him around and
he said and finally about halfway
through the thing you want to get some
lunch uni you don't eat Chinese right I
said I know the best mr. Leno and so I
took him to the place that like you know
my dad wouldn't even take me it was too
expensive but he says hey my dad used to
go that place is expensive come on we're
gonna eat over here just as good you see
kids anyway so he said come on you do I
hate my life come on eat with me I mean
so throw you a comedian they said yes
sir how much time you got
I said I got about maybe eight minutes
he said good I'm glad to hear that most
people most comedians ask how much time
we got I got two hours and I get through
there who wants to hear two hours of
comedy material either have twenties all
you need and be in LA 20 minutes become
a star you don't have that you don't
have anything just get five minutes that
kills if you don't have that you don't
have anything if you don't find me the
kills every time everywhere you go every
time then you don't have anything so I
said just work on your five minutes so
that was like that grace advised ain't
nobody could ever told me yeah these are
thank you so I just instead what I said
I said some no Robert
nobody gave you a roadmap of how to be
successful in comedy so I just worked on
the next six minutes I work in that and
Nick that worked on that one and
eighteen months later I perform that
same bit on on the Letterman Show I
didn't have much more than that and then
did you move out here Rob after that
after the first yet literally the next
day I moved to LA so okay Rob and I met
each other cuz Rob was yeah we were in
Fort Lauderdale I get a call Rob
Schneider how long does this be give me
dude this one's been 10 years ago yeah
he's just and I just came back to his
stand-up yeah in the end and they said
Robert matters is back in comedy and
they said something he goes look I know
it's your show but can you co-headline
he thought I have a problem where were
you at my house Brian is a master well
ok right you know he's a master of
stand-up and like he just you see well I
was just I've been doing it I was at the
boiling point I was uh I was you I was
like you're a Road Dogg I was the and I
was and I had my than a Road Dogg
because Road dogs can get bitter and
whatever they're eating the Brian is
different because Brian is like was
celebrating and aware of the art form
but not bitter from it and then making
fun of the art form while he's doing it
or affected by it he knows he's there to
a nerd
at a very high level he entertains from
like the jokes that are interesting he
knows I gonna make I want to make it
interesting for the audience and then to
physicalize it and perform it and I
walked ahead it was like whoa this is
stand-ups at another level now when you
see Brian okay because I learned so much
thank you because I just got back back
into doing stand-up and his saying you
might know the best in the world yeah I
met a guy I used to cook so much time
off because of movies and unfortunately
I was busy making movies and making
millions they said he wants to go ahead
Michael yeah quite like they thought I'd
be like no as your feature I go no of
course I drop something right and you
know that's a stamp it's a good thing it
was Brian cuz a lot of guys he goes I
know a ton of guys kind of community
goes like absolutely not I'll [ __ ] that
I would have said no thank you but you
know the thing about it was Joe it's
it's uh it's something that you have to
I respect the artform too much of just
like do a victory lap with it I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna be the best that and
only do it and the only way to do that
is you have to jump into it because I
was making movies and stuff I wasn't
doing stand-up and I I you know like I
said I don't want to just do it just to
make some money or just to do that what
made you about money well I said because
I in the back of my mind was like I
still never got to the point where I
felt I was great at it I never got to
that like you'd watch these other guys
you see Bill burr you see you know you
see Brian you see like Sarah Silverman
you see Chappelle at this incredible
level like there's always been great
stand-ups don't get me wrong but there's
it's still a relatively young art form
it's like spoken word jazz and it's just
like jazz just like rock and roll this
is an American art felicitous and it's a
spoken word jazz and it's still it's
still bike if you're talking from the
50s to now you're talking you know seven
is the 65 years in and it's there's
there's always been great comics has
never been as many at their peak at the
same time when it's been needed in this
time of unbelievable amounts of
censorship unbelievable amounts of like
people stuck in their dogmatic ways of
thinking and it's we have great
comedians thankfully like bill birnes
new special some Dave Chappelle's new
special is great and it's a just knocks
what it does is it gets most people are
not dogmatic and they're thinking an
open mind and they're just the fact that
it's the loudmouth
and it's the people who have access to
immediate outrage and that's the social
media and so they have that more robbed
that is what is now yes that's the
perception so you have you have
unfiltered real opinions about stuff
that you're not getting anywhere else
yeah that's so true so now you're you're
you're gonna you're back on tour a solid
year since then yeah great roadmap of
like and I feel like a good time I
weekend by the way that was a lot of fun
it was also funny cuz you could see like
cuz you were like you know I was like
watching you and I was very like you are
having so much more fun than me because
you had like it was so you got me with
so many places to go yeah well you got
me when I was literally doing that one
hour that was bet the boiling point like
I knew every I had you did outlays you
couldn't house that [ __ ] so grave I
remember I I knew I was gonna be I I
knew that I will and it's my house that
especially for a lot ago and he goes you
go on first I'll go on second and I go
and I he was much more famous but I was
like you know Rob I didn't say it but I
was like I don't think that's a great
idea because because he's doing a solid
I'm gonna set that place long and you're
gonna have to go and and you just you're
great but you just have been doing it as
long it be you didn't have getting back
in the ring and and he was so famous he
is so famous I wasn't then it was I
didn't want to so he goes don't worry
about it go ahead I can't say she looks
at me I'm her you said if you go you go
you're a [ __ ] flame thrower yes I told
you and you still haven't did well and
this is back to the point where it can
have been a better data do it rob kids
the brat Brian's one of the only guys in
comedy who well who think like that will
take care of you it's like remember when
we were first doing shows together I was
doing Tommy for I don't know maybe three
months and we're doing a show I forget
where is that some casino because you
know and they want to put this killer
like season Comicon before me and they
go what you guys when you get paid and
that and I went okay that I should
always open the show then Brian would go
yeah I went okay why don't you pay
that's fine have them on and then you
get word of it and just Nick's the whole
thing yeah you know what that's not
happening
my friends been doing Sanford three
months who's this guy use how long you
been doing it gives 15 years it's not
happening
you're not doing that now you're not
doing I got true and I come out at that
time I realize how big of a deal that
was yeah because I was like I'll be fine
I said everyone if you were a neophyte
you're new in this thing it's also
there's like a certain rhythm that he
know the audience and you know it
happened and he wants to make it a good
experience for you because when you're
progressing from an early place it's
important that you don't get so knocked
yeah that it takes you a six months or a
year to recover correct because it's a
look stand up and you know this and the
great stand ups like you know you see
these guys commit suicide or whatever
you go like oh god how could he do it if
you've been in this business long enough
harder to take him so long
Jesus Christ yeah is that you know
because it comes at a psychic price so
it's very important that Brian looked
out for you and said like hey dude he's
not let's not give him a hit right now
that's gonna take him back to where he's
building up slowly so that we take care
of each other especially if it's
somebody who's a performer and who loves
to do it and yeah and would there's no
it's no it's not like I got vlogging I
could almost find her I'm just doing it
guys ROI and they also respect the
people and there's some times if you see
a comedian it's like it's not
professional and a guy [ __ ] that guy but
if you know a guy who's really working
and trying to build themselves then it's
your you know it's your eyes an artist
it's it's your you know you've been
lucky enough to get into position if you
can help somebody give them a little
stump a little if some guys would go I
don't let me go out there you hate that
stuff but it's good to have somebody
better than you what the hit play tennis
to get better at it like for instance
like I remember when Adam Sandler stereo
start first have like a hundred million
dollar movies and he said I'm gonna go
see my new friend today and I said okay
come on so who is it go you'll figure it
out so I'm driving I more than Bellaire
bigger bigger homes of holy [ __ ] no
bigger homes like another gigantic
bigger home and he goes Bing Bing Bing
on this gigantic fence you know who sir
that the fence that's got like you know
it's got plants on it that are groomed
it [ __ ] who's got a house like that
there's another level I'd know you're
here
this like rich people in this [ __ ]
reach so this is like it was Dustin
Hoffman's house and he said Lena we
played basketball and he just got a new
basketball thing this is like 20 years
ago
and he's playing and his son
out there and ever and like and I
remember I was at that time I was in
better shape and I blew by him and then
the next thing I said I probably
shouldn't have done that and then he
went in the house he's at funk I don't
play but anyway but he was talking to us
anything you know you guys got a you
know play with better people you got to
get directives we're better than you
otherwise if you just doing it you know
that you got it's like tennis you gotta
play somebody who's hitting the ball
hard and you better than you learn
something new hits and it's right you
know you have to do that so I would say
like right now you know there are like
you know so Jerry Seinfeld said like in
the eighties until 1975 there were 40
comedians and eight of them were good
yeah in 1985 there were 4000 comedians
and eight of them were good so but you
have now you have real masters at it
that are really at that level
III got a look at this a stand up as
like rock and roll like in the 60s where
you had like you had the Beatles you
also had the kinks and you had though
there's so many the doors and you had
like so you have you're writing a book
about that right oh yeah
what was it why was there a Renaissance
then because did they feel like they
were changing the world with their music
or was you had a lot of things going on
you have to understand that's like the
art is like a tree you know there's like
a lot of branches on it it ain't just
one doesn't tree just doesn't go up here
it's right let's this and so you had
like very interesting time in 1961-62
where you had like you know the sexual
revolution and that came from an ending
of censorship because the censorship
ended by when they first started a Henry
Miller's book tropic of cancer I was
able to come over get Casey you know Ken
Casey's people had something to say so
what happened was these books were
numbered over anyway when they stopped
thinking they were optimistic enough to
believe that their music and what they
had to say and people were apparently
henshin them and people were like hope
you know when Elvis looks like John
Lennon said when Elvis Elvis died you
know you can't die when he's 42 he died
I'm gonna join the army you know when he
became part of it and then you know
music kind of got really safe after that
and then I could like you know it's my
party and I've got anyone from like
Elvis you know Elvis like you know being
you know of all the Lord you step on my
blue suede shoes to like
it's my power again cria so it was like
music was ready and then buddy it was
perfect timing cuz Buddy Holly died in
59 they only like it 27 to write like
Buddy Holly
oh you shredding Buddy Holly was 20
Chaplin he had 20 20 top Jim number-one
hits I think find out what musicians
died at 27 us this way 7 it's Kurt
Cobain jobs job Jimi Hendrix Jim
Morrison Morrison yeah I mean it's
but anyway so you have so you had me you
had this uh you know incredible things
happen at the same time and then
rock-and-roll just kind of came through
already Canyon - Barry so many young
people and teenagers who were wanted
something yeah man they were looking for
something different but what does that
book you're reading 69 68 or with Ryan
Jones it was it Sun Laurel Canyon all
the bantha so I do think now you have
like these incredible comedians that are
like a while ago yeah so might you know
on I mom as if I'm working on it to be
one of them you know it's been taking
ten years and I think it's like that
thing about like you know you got to be
in there several thousand hours you're
spots especially yeah I did but nothing
I wasn't proud of that one I feel like I
did it and like but this one that I'm
working on now I feel like you know it's
just it's gonna be a really high quality
I love where do you do most your rep
that rough you know what believe it or
not like I like I loved working in LA
and it really is the Comedy Store is the
most important comedy club in the world
the one right here and you know what
they just never had enough money in the
old days to ruin it yeah you know you
know you were in like you know there's
like a club is like this
Columbus it was like improv is it was
great you know it's a kind of a
restaurant it wasn't that great I mean
the room didn't look that great but it
was perfect the energy in there it's not
we fixed it we got a real Club and it
ain't as good yeah they wrote well that
never happened to the store stays the
same the store has been like a dumpy
dive and that's what you need you need
the audience to hide and it's perfect so
it's a great place if you can get it out
of your own head that they're that
they're not judging you the try stuff
and like it's interesting you see the
greatest comics in the world to go up
there and it's a little in their head
that they're being judged it's a little
bit right well you don't like a lot of
comics do new material then yeah some of
them do Rogan burr will go up that's
when you spot a lot it that's what
you're supposed to do but a lot of guys
especially if it's like Tuesday night
we're its killers like the other night
when it was frickin Jeselnik Joey Diaz
Theo von oh yeah you just go before them
and do all new material while they're
doing hitters no tough man well the
thing is you can do like the greatest
things when I got you know who talked me
into doing truthfully talking about into
doing what I was doing grown-ups which
in 2009 and Chris Rock said you know you
got to get back up there and do it man
and I said well you're the best at it
not how I'm never gonna be as good as
you said he said no nice he said you
could be the best at this you could just
you could be you know and you just got
to do it I don't know what I talked
about just talking all be talking to me
every day life
just the way he would approach things
what he would talk about and the way he
would he would come at it from a new
angle he's mirrorless and I've seen him
write full house right on stage he came
up on stage with me like I was letting
afraid for that song he's a guy who
would do all new [ __ ] he came up right
after the Boston bombing okay I was on
stage performing I was talking about any
we're at rob I was at upstate it was in
New York like Nyack or something like
that there's a nice Club up there yeah
and all of a sudden is this guy like you
know because they're always looking
trying to figure out what's happening
you thinking of the next thing you
thinking of okay did they dig that one
physically what am I gonna do next you
know it's late and then I'll sit at the
corner my I see somebody's walking on
the stage from the left side and I said
who is what you know and like it's this
guy gonna stab me this guy gonna attack
me this guy you're gonna is this that is
this the bouncers they're a fire all the
stuff that goes through your head when
there's somebody walking on the stage
who you can't really see and it was
Chris Rock coming onstage and I just
said oh my goodness when crazy and I
just handed him the mic and he's right
after and he did that joke about like
you know the Boston bombing you know
where they they put the bomb at the end
at the finish line can you imagine and I
go where's he going they said they
imagine that you run 26 miles and then
somebody yells run and I were like oh my
god genius and this guy and then he did
like another ten minutes and like the
thing about it and I remember because at
the same time because I got back into
doing this in social media so like you
know the [ __ ] that like you can get from
whatever if you make a mistake of a
tweet of a joke whatever and I just
remember calling him because you've got
so much [ __ ] off doing this one routine
on Saturday Night Live and I call him
and I said dude I said like it was a
hilarious joke and I said I can't
believe that anyone would have
a problem with that and he just said
[ __ ] oh yeah he's the best okay get SEC
then why are you even looking at that
[ __ ] is the same thing like Lewbert said
that to me you can say anything you want
it's it's it's eight people on Twitter
welcome yeah but the per this is false
perception because remember in the old
days mean this is what I talk about in
my act I go like remember in the old
days when you when you complaining
you're the complaint for a long time
before anybody realized that you were
angry about them it took now there's
just immediate out you know acts is a
immediate in your magic phone to express
outrage the core with your patient is
immature
remember used to get a piece of paper
and a pen you had to get an address you
know it's a yeah the call and indeed I
know I'm talking passed around here
[ __ ] all right and then you had to
make it investme at the bystander leave
your house American Marc Maron said oh
he made Marc Maron said he was talking
about Jesus and making fun of Jesus and
this woman in front goes ah uh-uh you
cannot talk about Jesus that way and he
goes oh I can and I will so he keeps
going they get up and leave him the guy
calls the next day and he wants to sue
the club for defamation hey let me tell
you cuz you're defaming Jesus Christ
that's why the [ __ ] free speech is
the whole ball of wax anybody like I
can't believe this being attacked on the
left side you can't talk about
everything the thing about like this you
can't talk about politics it's like
politics is everything politics is the
road you drive on the food you eat the
water you drink also what's up dudes
they'll tell the truth is that there are
a lot of people who are very intolerant
on both sides of course but it's oh yeah
the first time in on the Left they're
talking back to back but they may see
the other way no one's they will censor
you they will get you will lose your job
you will get shadow back if you have to
use like if you do have a strong opinion
about something yeah the other side of
that will try to ruin you absolutely it
is a but at this point people know that
and people are getting hip to the fact
that like you know there is a you know
it's it's a culture of destruction yeah
culture of cancel culture and whatever
you want to call it
I'm hip to it they're getting hip to it
I argue but you have to like you saying
they're not they are yeah I'm thinking
like hey if I don't pee out of my I
gotta come hard - okay cool take a pee
break we should start recording that's
fun oh yeah two hours you're awesome
I can't believe I look at my clock okay
it's fun uh well Rob Schneider I've got
to go to a reading okay get to it this
is month we appreciate your hobby yeah
man good luck with your point you know
thank you yet see what happens is the
podcast and I really appreciate a learn
what you guys are doing here and thanks
so much for showing me the ropes pal
anytime bro good to see you may have
Schneider ladies and gentlemen that it
be that's it I gotta go gonna be in
Tampa just gotta text me you're in Tampa
so Sony I'm gonna be in Tampa Tampa
September 27th and 28th where and at the
Tampa improv oh yeah that's great and
I'm in I'm in Houston 20th and 21st next
week and then after that Denver Comedy
Works downtown 26 the 29th I'm gonna be
at you know the great club and what's a
mine this weekend where am I gonna be
the city no come on it's Florida it's
it's Jacksonville Jacksonville Florida
so which is fun
comedy zone Rob Schneider Jacksonville
Florida this weekend go see him or Die
this Lafont kid we're out